alors si c'est ça
mettez vous aux côtés des talents franck
gaston franck gastambide écrit ça vous
va très bien ses talons je vous le dis
on en reste là bas je sais que voulez
vous rapprocher de moi mais reste un cas
pas puisque c'est un duel vous allez
prendre un des cha cun d'accord alors un
des chacun on va voir combien vous
faites avec les des way l'équipe qui
fait le meilleur total
ouais et sauver l'équipe qui fait le
moins bon total perd alors si vous
perdez le premier jet de dés vous devrez
faire à la dance à l'autre pendant 20
secondes
c'est la tendance à l'autre et c'est
franck qui devra danser pour claudia ils
veulent voir alors on mettra une chaise
inquiétez pas et moi malheureusement
c'est gilles verdez qui va danser pour
moi
attention à l'egypte pour ce premier jet
c'est parti on y va top
allez-y vous n'êtes pas mal ah ah ah ah
ah oui 9
oui
allez-y jules à tcc parti pour qu'on
fasse plus de 9 à eau
non
bon bah c'est pas clair
au coude à coude à alléger claudia rock
allez-y faites vous plaisir
ouah
aujourd'hui
oui
je tarde à venir laissent le client est
prêt quand je vois ça je me dis que
heureusement qu'on n'a pas perdu
voilà on connaît bien attention le
deuxième défi il va falloir gare où là
c'est un goulot pour 2 gosier je vous
montre un peu la bouteille c'est quoi
quoi quoi de l'alcool d'aller voir dans
vous allez voir alors vous allez voir
c'est très simple si non il va falloir
que va falloir boire ensemble la même
bouteille
ohlala oui c'est pas passifs genou plus
grande bouche que lui aussi mais c'est
pas grave ça va passer attention vous
d'où tirez l'aider en premier c'est
parti je suis là j'ai vraiment pas envie
de le perdre là pour le coup autant la
danse je m'en fichais encore mouillée ce
montant là gilles vous êtes angoissé un
peu un peu on voit s'étaler ce2 est le 2
le 1 le 1 l'as au qu'ils sont chanceux
au qu'ils sont chanceux ne payons pas
d'effet mais ne crions pas victoire trop
tôt
s'il faut pas trop là aussi les trucs
qu'ils mais non je vous jure que non
mais j'ai jamais rien truqués vous
croyez quoi
ainsi c'est truqué dans les chaussures
colorées si le tapis ça a tiré sa tour
allez devoir boire ensemble cette
bouteille mais c'est très sympa le but
c'est qu'on boive ensemble
lol c'est un goût un boulot oui mais un
boulot à travers une policière valser
leurs me trouver des trucs et sa
charnière koné la mairie met à bouger en
bois
le prochain week-end hébreu soit
commission commission des micros et
huawei a oui oui mais toi je t'ai pas de
boire regarde non mais pas mais non
ensemble c'est qu'il est très rare que
nous ressentons
alors juste deux minutes avant qu'on
fasse la dernière vague jean-luc masson
cours de zumba merci jean luc hallé et
enfin pour le dernier pour le dernier il
va falloir faire une scène de roméo et
juliette une déclaration d'amour avec un
accent d'accord l'accent que vous voulez
vous souhaitiez ces cas l'accent vous
peut dire par exemple l'accent je sais
pas ça vient ça viendra comme ça rien
vous feront vous ferez l'action que vous
voudrez vous à quoi je ne sais pas keira
d'accord j'espère tu veux pas perdre mon
garage envie d'entendre un collant sans
prôner oui le cage a laissé partir mon
attention c'est parti
j'arrive
de france je prends vraiment l'accent
caméra moi je me vois
alors c'est tout d'accord donner l'asile
vers des dons nous fait l'accent keira
je fais vous faites vous faites du liet
on qu'avec l'accent keira et jeffrey
romeo avec l'as en chinois formés robert
pourquoi tu remettras nitoo père et
abdique tonneau ou si tu veux pas sûr de
me mettre à pleurer la mort bah je
l'écoutais encore plus répondre
tellement d'ennemis ta g en tête est
tombée au toit local mode juliette
commandes en tête et au cou cassé j aime
tous oui c'est gênant
sinon
je savais que je n'aurais jamais dû me
faire à deux c'est le geste
ouais c'est vrai petit déjeuner